اذا سرايا القدس الان مشاهدينا الكرام
اكدوا استشهاده ثلاثه من قادتها في
الغارات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
البيان الان من اسراء القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي يؤكد
استشهاد وينعى الشهداء الثلاثه القاده
الذين استشهدوا في الغارات الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه كان الحديث يدور عن طارق عز
الدين المبعد من الضفه الغربيه من جنين
الذي حرر في صفقه شليط وكذلك خليل
البهتيني
وجهاد غنام امين سر المجلس العسكري الذي
استشهد ايضا جراء قصف منزله في مدينه رفح
هذه الصور ما زالت تاتينا من مدينه غزه
لسمائها وكذلك للمستشفيات
المستشفيات التي ما زالت تستقبل اعداد
الشهداء هؤلاء هم القاده جهاد الغنام
وخليل البتيني وطارق عز الدين اكدت سرايا
القدس وائل اعود اليك وائل الدحدوح القدس
اذا في بيان رسمي تؤكد استشهاد القاده
الثلاثه
هذا صحيح محمد هو البيان الاول بعد عمليه
الاغتيال الصادر عن سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي وهو بيان
ان نعي للشهداء الثلاثه القاده كما وصفهم
هو جهاد شاكر غنام امين سر المجلس العسكري
لسرايا القدس والشهيد خليل صلاح البهتيني
عضو المجلس العسكري وقائد المنطقه
الشماليه في سرايا القدس والشهيد طارق
محمد عز الدين احد قاده العمل العسكري في
الضفه الغربيه الذين ارتقوا في هذه
العمليه عمليه الاغتيال فجر اليوم
وسرايا القدس تحدثت بان هذا النعي وهذا
الاستشهاد للقاده وزوجاتهم وعدد من
ابنائهم تؤكد اكدت سرايا القدس بانها لن
تزيد المقاومه الفلسطينيه الا عزما ولن
تدفع على مغادره المواقع وستبقى المقاومه
مستمره اذا هذا هو رد الفعل الاول من
سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري وبالتالي كانت
الاسماء التي ترددت بعد
دقائق من عمليات الاغتيال كانت هي اسماء
صحيحه وبالتالي هذا الاغتيال اغتيال كبير
يشبه الى حد كبير وربما اكبر من ذلك
الاستهداف في شهر اب من العام الماضي
عندما اغتالت الطائرات الاسرائيليه
قياديين بارزين من سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي قائد
المنطقه الجنوبيه خالد منصور وقائد
المنطقه الشماليه تيسير الجعبري ايضا في
محافظتي غزه هنا على مقربه من هذا المكان
الذي نتواجد فيه وايضا محافظه رفح جنوبي
قطاع غزه
وبالتالي هنا هنا ربما ياتي التشابه بين
هاتين العمليتين اسرائيل تاخذ زمام
المبادره بعد قرارات من المستوى السياسي
الاسرائيلي وتخطيط ايضا من المستوى الامني
والعسكري الاسرائيلي تاخذ زمام المبادره
وتبادر بهذا الاختيار رفيع المستوى
لقياديات وازنه لقياديين ويعني من هذا
الطراز الرفيع والمهم في في الجناح
العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي وبالتالي هي ربما
ايضا في في ربما تشابه اخر لما جرى في
عمليه اب او التصعيد في اب من العام
الماضي عندما استهدفت قيادات من سرايا
القدس من الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلام